foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
remember
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's up foreign
come on
[Music]
foreign
from me
[Music]
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the Dunya the three Muslims today I
have the pleasure of sitting once again
with Dr Ali at Tyson how you doing today
it's a pleasure and honor to be sitting
here with you again alhamdulillah I
think it's gonna be a really good stream
for those of you who are unaware we did
a stream recently with Dr Alia Tai
um very very qualified individual why
don't you tell us a little bit about
your studies
uh well um
I've always been a student of religion
um kind of a perennial student of
religion not a not a perennialist a
perennial student of religion so there's
a big difference there
but uh you know I've done a lot of
independent study eventually I got
around to doing a master's degree in in
uh biblical studies I focus on New
Testament and uh biblical languages
and then eventually did a PhD
and basically he did something broadly
speaking it's comparative theology but
more specifically speaking I did a
Muslim hermeneutic of the Gospel of John
if people want to look that up they can
if they can decipher it I look back at
it now and I don't I don't understand
half of it so but basically comparative
theology
amazing amazing all right so and we
actually have young Don here with us
today in the Stream hope you're doing
well my brother and I hope that you
enjoy this stream and as always you're
always welcome welcome up if you uh have
the time to hop on so with that being
said a lot of people accuse me of
clickbait I I don't know why a lot of
them don't believe me on this they think
I'm just making it up so inshallah we're
gonna go ahead we're actually Gonna Play
a clip from yongdon's stream that he did
a few days ago
so you guys can see and hear for
yourself and if at any point
um Dr atai you want to jump in uh please
you know do not hesitate to do so
all right Bismillah but since while I
was at it testing all of these beliefs
these lies that I've inherited from
mainstream Church Andy
I said well how about the Trinity then
now I had no problem with the Trinity I
love the Trinity when you know I've had
Muslims join my Discord and I've debated
them and proven to them that the Trinity
is true the Trinity is true why because
according to mainstream Christian
culture to deny the Trinity is to deny
God
to deny the Trinity is to deny Jesus
Yahweh everything all together as if
they don't they aren't even real
I never for a moment
considered the possibility that man has
miscategorized
these people
I mean Jesus sure does call himself
God's son over and over and over and
over
tells us there is only one true God the
Father this is a message that is
repeated throughout the Bible in several
places
and so I was like you know what
let's let's look into this let's test it
and I tested it and tested it and
it came up short
wait a minute
do you know how many times the the term
God the Father occurs in the Bible 19.
you know how many times God the son or
God the Holy Spirit occurs in the Bible
zero
wonder why
that's interesting
yeah and so I was like you know let's
really dig deep now I dug deep looked
into it pretty thoroughly for two weeks
and then I started to to share this
quietly
right by discussing it with people I'm
gonna pause there for a second for the
next minute or so he goes on to mention
how the Christians accuse him of being a
lot of things one of which was a Muslim
which I don't know why that's like an
insult also like oh you're just a Muslim
you but uh I think it's kind of funny
but yeah so what are your thoughts so
far how many people do you think
actually go down this route of
discovering that the Trinity is not
exactly something that is inherited
Through the Bible
yeah I mean there's there have always
been Unitarian Christians
um I'm more interested I mean I'm
interested in hearing more from him but
it seems like he uh is an Aryan
Christian so not not Aryan as in like
the Aryan race obviously but uh the 4th
century
a presbyter in Alexandria who was
defeated at the Council of nicaea in 325
of the Common Era Arius of Alexandria
right who basically said that and he had
the same basic Canon as athanasius right
but that's another issue we can talk
about as a Christian Canon right it's a
really interesting history but you know
Aries had the Gospel of John he believed
in the Gospel of John he had the Paul
line Epistles he believed in those as
well but he came to the conclusion as
this brother did that the trinity
or not even the Trinity at this point
because the Trinity didn't actually
become Orthodox Christianity until 381
which is a few decades after nicaea wow
but he came to the conclusion that that
the Son of God cannot be
ontologically equal with God the Father
right so he would consider that Arius
consider that to be totally heretical
right
um that God the father is the only one
who is truly God and this is John 17 3.
I mean again I mean we talked about some
of this last time as well that if you
ask a Christian at random where does
Jesus claim to be God or where is it
stated explicitly that Jesus peace be
upon Him is God in the New Testament uh
most Christians I think would quote
something from the Gospel of John John
17 3 this is eternal life to know you
the only true God and that's 17 3 but if
you go back to 17 1 it says very clearly
the Evangelist will call him John for
now we don't know who wrote the Gospel
of John just out of convenience we'll
call him John
but he says that this is a prayer a high
Priestly prayer that Jesus offers to the
father he's speaking to the father and
he says that the father is the only one
who is truly God
right and that's what the Greek actually
says the only one who is truly God to
know you the only true God the only one
is truly God and to know so the verb is
implied in the second clause and to know
that Jesus Jesus Christ whom thou has
sent wow right uh so that's um that's
that's pretty close to our shahada right
that there is no God but Allah
and
all of the prophets before him are sent
of God
right so he he seems to come very close
to the uh the Aryan position Aries also
because there's adverse in Colossians 1
15. I don't know if this brother quoted
that I didn't I I watched some of this
uh which you just showed from his
podcast
um just a few minutes of it but I
imagine that he probably quoted 115 of
Colossians which is pseudo Pauline I
mean Paul didn't wrote didn't write
Colossians according to the vast
majority of historical Scholars but
whoever wrote Colossians he refers to
the Sun as the firstborn of creation
right yeah and that's that's just very
clear that that the sun is created it
does he doesn't say Jesus Christ is
created yeah because a trinitarian could
argue here that yeah Jesus's body as it
were you know is is created his flesh
body is not eat preach eternal
about the uh the essence uh that dwells
within the incarnated Lagos within the
flesh
is is free Eternal but but pseudo Paul
here in Colossians is clearly talking
about uh the sun he's the firstborn of
all creation so so Arius believe that
Jesus was
that's the term that he used
literally means uh the most perfect or
the first of all creation wow but he's
still created
right and uh the church fathers who met
at nicia who anathematized areas and
it's a very interesting history I highly
recommend Christians especially
Christians that are struggling with this
issue of Trinity you don't have to let
go of Jesus when you let go of the
Trinity you can continue to love Jesus
okay Muslims love Jesus Unitarian
Christians love Jesus uh but but Arius
was anathematized that nice and if you
actually read the Nicene Creed it's very
short
I think it froze a little bit hopefully
we didn't lose them
oh no
doctor if you can hear me I think we
lost you a little bit
once again inshallah he might leave and
come back in a second but
I do want to bring up yongdong's comment
I think it's very important since we are
talking about the brother that we do
voice anything that he he comments
anything he says so he says Shalom
Brothers Jesus is the true Lord of lords
king of kings and uh we lost doctor
inshallah he'll be back soon
one second
all right the one who holds the keys to
life and death eternal life but yahwah
riable eternity being an error this is
is really why I appreciate you young Don
because
like I mentioned because we spoke
earlier and like I mentioned I really
think you're a sincere guy you know when
I was watching your stream I really just
heard a very sincere brother who is you
don't have a problem quoting a verse
that Muslims brought to you earlier and
being honest about what Jesus said and
about the creedal issues in Christianity
even you mentioning that like you you
were worried about bringing this to the
general populace of your audience
because you didn't want anyone to donate
something crazy or try and put you on
the spot I felt that man and I I respect
that greatly because genuinely I think
you're a very sincere dude
says not Aryan Brothers I believe we
must keep the Torah and that Jesus
existed before his Incarnation okay
I see I'll show that Dr Alia Tai when he
gets back Insha'Allah again I'm not sure
exactly what happened but
so
Dawn
if you're still with us
Jesus existed in what sense before his
Incarnation so we we we understand that
you believe that is it the essence of
Jesus or is it the body of Jesus
and do you believe that
oh okay we got him we got him back with
us
hey welcome back
I don't know what half my computer just
kind of crashed on me it's okay no
worries no reason so we actually have
young Don he left to come he said he's
not Aryan I believe we must keep the
Torah and that Jesus existed before his
incarnation
okay yeah I mean
that's that's also arius's position
oh really I bet you have to keep the
Torah
um but uh I mean
to me that even
Oracle Jesus
um because of his office as a prophet
ameliorated the the mitzvot of the Torah
in other words he probably taught a more
sort of liberal
not liberal sense that we know of sort
of left-wing or anything like that uh
but an easier version if you will of the
Torah yeah right uh and then in Acts
chapter 15 for what it's worth I mean
the book of Acts is probably written in
the second century this is where the
scholarship is leading to now
right
um probably early second century but in
Acts chapter 15
um the uh
James the just who is the successor of
Jesus needs to be upon him in Jerusalem
um that was you know Acts chapter 15 is
all about the Jerusalem Council how much
of the law do we have to impose upon
these gentle converts to this new way
right
um so uh their decision was that
Gentiles do not have to follow all of
the law essentially all they have to
follow is the seven noahitic laws
right
um while as uh whereas um the the Jewish
Christians really have to keep most of
the uh Commandments uh can you search
him either is that okay
yeah yeah yeah
okay
that's very interesting and and I do
want to get into all of this very very
soon I have a few questions about early
Christian dumb and how the the Jewish
Christians you know kind of might have
had a different belief to the Gentile
Christians because
it seems to be the case that there was a
lot of speculation in the early years of
Christianity you know from 30 33 A.D
onwards
um and I I was wondering why did Paul's
christology of Jesus flourish the way
that it did is it because he was the
only one preaching to the Gentiles is it
is it because what he said just made the
most sense is because what he said was
true about Jesus
why do you think his christology stuck
and like the ebonite's belief or
facilities his belief didn't
yeah it's an interesting question we
don't really know the exact reasons you
know certainly Paul uh was not the only
one teaching in Gentile lands I mean
from Paul's own hand we know that men
from James would follow him in his wake
and try to essentially correct his
version of the Gospel
you know so these sort of standard
exegesis of Galatians I think still is
FC Bauer
you know I don't think he's been really
debunked so basically you know Paul goes
to galatia to preach his gospel and he
calls it my gospel
oh
evangelizes the city of galatia or the
the province of galatia and then he
leaves and then uh and then
um
Apostles from Jerusalem
he's James Sonia nazarenes most likely
sent by James because James was still
you know in the 50s I mean James was
martyred like 62. this is probably 55
something like that so undoubtedly
they're sent by James and at one point
he actually identifies
his enemies as men from James
and who is James a lot of Christians
haven't heard of James James is the
brother of Jesus whatever that means
maybe his cousin or half brother but he
is the leader of the Christians for 30
years so he sends these Apostles in the
galatia to correct Paul's gospel
basically and Paul hears of this uh and
then he writes a very strongly worded
letter back to the Galatians you know
warning them about you know a uh heteron
ewangelion which means a different
gospel and a different Jesus and he says
even if
looks like the uh Wi-Fi is a bit a
little bit choppy but it's okay
inshallah
okay let me let me take the time to put
up Don's comment Paul didn't preach a
different gospel his words have been
misunderstood by Muslims and Christians
alike
okay no original origin and um
if obviously you know if that's what you
believe that's a non-issue we're just
here to discuss you know based on the
evidences so similarly to you know how
you were mentioning the you know a
certain passage was put into the Bible
that was not there originally or
how the Trinity was inferred into
Christianity because you know what did
they call it churchianity or something
like that that's an interesting term
um we're saying that there may be more
to the New Testament there may be more
to the Bible there may be more to
Christianity and early Christendom than
most people are aware of so I think what
Dr aliatai is referring to here
um would be
I think it's I think it's in Galatians
things that's what he mentioned it's in
one of the early books where he speaks
about
um whoever he writes to whether it's the
Corinthians or whatever
um he he says basically you know how
dare you accept a different gospel if
anyone preaches to you something that's
other or opposed to my gospel even if
it's me or an angel from heaven do not
believe it what I got was from you know
uh was from God himself from Heaven
itself
please tell Dr Ali Italia I love him and
foreign
once he gets back
so that's the I think that's what he was
referring to
and I want everyone to know we we
honestly I I highly respect yongdon I
really do appreciate his shift not
because you know he he agrees more with
Muslims but because it shows that he is
sincere you know the fact that he's
willing to go to his vastly trinitarian
audience and proclaim a thing and for
his own reason he said that he doesn't
want to be held accountable by God I
think that's a very Noble thing
Paul's writings have been misunderstood
he preached keeping the Torah if I was
on my office I would hop on and explain
the perspective of Paul no worries bro
no worries and shall I take your time if
you want you're always invited if you
want to hop on like on Saturday or
whatever it's completely up to you bro
like I mentioned um you are always
invited
yeah he's uh Dr Alia Tai is is great uh
his Wi-Fi is not so great unfortunately
but
alhamdulillah he um he doesn't know what
he's talking about I think he he does a
great job of presenting that as well
he's very uh you know well studied as
well
so
on that note that Paul did not preach
giving up the
the the law there was a verse in regards
to that I completely set my mind I'm
gonna try and find inshallah in the
meantime
all right
welcome back
yeah my computer is just overheating I
see
yeah it keeps shutting down on me I
gotta get a new computer I think that's
okay uh maybe maybe joining on your
phone might be a little easier if it
crashes again
oh yeah I join on my phone I can
probably do that right
is that what you did yeah
no no I can't you know let me if you
want to try it
I guess it does it one more time we'll
try it okay okay inshallah sounds good
so
while the Wi-Fi was trying to stop our
amazing uh dialogue young Don mentioned
that um Paul did not preach to give up
the Torah and to abandon it and that
these words are misunderstood or
misconstrued
um by some Christians and some Muslims
um
I mean the the laws nailed to the cross
right
uh we are free from the bondage of the
law I mean very clearly in his letters I
would say is genuine Corpus
he's uh antinomian that is to say that
he's speaking against the law I mean and
yeah the way that acts the book of Acts
portrays Paul he agrees with James in
the book of Acts that you know James
tells him to go pay for these four men
who are taking the vow of the Nazarite
to prove that you follow the law says
James that's what Paul does so whoever
wrote uh acts which is the same author
as Luke will call him Luke
um I guess is trying to defend Paul by
saying that no Paul did in fact follow
some of the law uh and so like one of
the things that James says that is that
you have to tell you have to basically
uh you have to basically tell people not
to eat meat that is sacrificed by Idols
this is one of these sort of statutes or
Commandments that comes out of the
Jerusalem Council in Acts chapter 15 but
in Paul's letters he says there's
nothing wrong with eating such meat
right circumcision will will profit you
nothing circumcision of the heart is is
his stress right and and he's he's very
derogatory towards
these Jerusalem Apostles by calling them
you know the dogs of the circumcision
and he says I wish that the knife would
slip and they would emasculate
themselves completely
um you know so uh I would say that the
vast majority of Pauline Scholars would
disagree with that notion and say that
Paul is definitely uh at some level an
antinomian that is to say that he's
against the the Torah of Moses to a
significant degree
um and that's basically the Christianity
that that one today I didn't what was I
saying before uh my computer crashed
again I was trying to make a point but I
oh I was saying about the book of
Galatians yeah
um yeah so uh so yeah so the standard
sort of exegesis is that
is that definitely there were there were
other Christians in the Gentile world
that were in the world that were
evangelizing uh a different Gospel
according to what Paul is saying uh and
this is coming out of Jerusalem this is
coming from James you know so very early
on
even in Paul's day even in the 50s
there's multiple versions of
Christianity
all right and I think I think that's
something that's very interesting I'm
going to put up a comment from Young Don
and then inshallah I want to make a
general actually let me make my point
first because I think the comments can
open up a greater discussion I think
it's very important that we look at the
Bible from a historical perspective and
not just a religious one or a
theological one the reason I say that is
because it's very it's very clear that
these are letters being written in
response to beliefs in response to other
letters in response to circumstances
that are going on at the time and as
soon as you contextualize the letters in
that sense it really does make sense
um and this is something I mentioned to
you briefly in messages before that you
know when you read James the first
letter of James you see the messaging is
is so honestly I would say very
muslim-like to be honest there's a lot
of very beautiful things in there being
said about you know keeping up the law
and being sincere and persevering
through tough times and being joyful
through these tough times it's very a
lot of Muslim Concepts taking care of
the orphans and the widows these are
beautiful things that you will also find
in Islam unfortunately uh I don't think
that it is authentically written by by
James but rather someone who claimed to
be James Joseph forgery unfortunately
but it is deemed to be one of the
earliest if not the earliest thing that
was written in out of the 27 books in
the New Testament when you contrast to
that with what Paul was writing it it
really does differ in the content and
what is being said and I think that is
for very clear contextual reasons
historically who he who he's writing to
and uh the exact message he's trying to
get across now I do want to bring up
this comment from Young Don he quoted
the verse
that says now brothers and sisters if I
still if I if I still preach
circumcision circumcision part of me why
am I still persecuted in that case the
offense of the Cross has been abolished
Galatians 5 11.
yeah I mean what what type of
circumcision I mean Paul goes on to say
uh that he's he preaches a circumcision
of of the heart right he's not requiring
Gentiles to be circumcised right I mean
he circumcises Timothy with his own
hands basically to placate Jewish
authorities but his position is that
Gentiles don't need to be circumcised I
would say the most Christians today are
not circumcised uh because they're
interpreting Paul
um holistically not just looking at one
verse or two but uh and Paul is a very
mystical writer so we'd have to see you
know what does he mean by circumcision
what does he mean by Resurrection
there's Paul is very difficult to read
sometimes very difficult to understand
even like what's his position on the
resurrection
uh even According to some historians
Paul doesn't believe in a in a corporeal
resurrection of Jesus that's why he
never talks about the empty tomb you'll
never hear the you never read the words
empty tomb in any genuine uh Pauline
letter you would think that was an
important uh event uh for Paul uh but
Paul talks about you know a a a a
physical body and a spiritual body right
uh a corpus that is sort of material
in a corpus that is uh that is panuma he
says that is uh that is spiritual that
is pure spirit and this is really more
of a Greek orientation unless we forget
that Paul is a bit of an amateur
philosopher Hellenistic philosopher
right so he's Jewish but not everything
a Jew says is according to Judaism I
mean Sam Harris is Jewish right uh
ethnically but uh he's certainly not an
authority on Judaism
um so the gospel authors it seems like
later on a few years after Paul's
letters because appealing to Jews with
the gospel is obviously uh important
um and so uh they started this
um uh this uh Narrative of an empty tomb
that the body was physically
reconstructed
um and Jesus left the tomb physically
um so
all right very interesting and for
everyone who's telling young Don to come
on he already mentioned that he's not in
his office he's not available for that
and uh I am very happy that he's with us
today even if it's just in the comments
and giving his thoughts there uh so
let's respect that he's not in his
office inshallah he says we'll schedule
a proper call soon I'll bring on an
expert on Pauline writings sounds great
Insha'Allah I would be happy to to
discuss that with you now I do want to
shift the conversation because it's
obviously it's not all about young Don I
think it's it's a tremendous kind of
Revelation that he's had
um in you know coming through this to
this conclusion through the scripture
but I do want to ask about
how did the Trinity come to be
theologically and how did the Bible
become Canon I know that it's something
that individual Church fathers were
working on by themselves
um throughout maybe one to two centuries
but it was something that was canonized
at some point and I heard that there
were 30 Gospels
26 of which were thrown away and four
were kept Mark Matthew Luke and John so
I would love for you to tell us a bit
about that
yeah so it's a really interesting
question that requires
um you know a substantive study of
Christian history but you know it's
interesting most people don't know this
but the Christian Canon was not
definitively and officially closed
uh until the 16th century okay the
Council of Trent
um this is a thousand years after Islam
right
um so I mean the first Christian Bishop
um who suggested
that these present 27 books should be
the only books to be read was athanasius
of Alexandria who was actually the
bishop of Arius right so Aries and and
athanasius were both at nicia and an
athanasius one won the day through vote
but his letter in 367 of the Common Era
it's called the 39th festal uh letter uh
he was he was the first one who said
just read these 27 books from Matthew to
Revelation our present Canon but that's
just one man's opinion uh basically and
uh you know Bart Ehrman did his
dissertation on didn't miss the blind
who was another
uh uh stahler in Alexandria a
contemporary of athanasius living in the
same time in the same city and denim is
the blinds Canon was different than
athanasius people think that athanasia
settled the Canon no he did he didn't do
that at all there was massive difference
of opinion into the fourth fifth sixth
seventh eighth Century as to what what
book should be included definitively in
what what book should be excluded you
know I mean there was a synod hippo in
right but this was a minor Council it's
not an ecumenical council right so
everyone at this time was basically
Catholic to put Orthodox had become
Catholic
um and so
um a a minor council is not binding upon
the Christian world only an ecumenical
council and that didn't happen until the
16th century uh and and contrary to
popular belief the Council of nicely had
nothing to do with
uh with the with the Canada New
Testament Canon it did not deal with the
Canon I think this rumor comes from Dan
Brown or something The Da Vinci Code or
something like that they're a Christian
apologists who will insist that the
Canon was settled in the second century
and this is just completely inaccurate
uh totally false I mean you had early
church fathers uh quoting from yeah
Matthew Mark Luke and John but they also
quoted from other things uh as well I
mean um sarafian uh one of the church
fathers at the time he actually believed
the gospel of Peter was authentic uh and
and endorsed it but then later on said
no actually it's it's heresy and uh
denim is the blind as I said earlier he
didn't accept second Peter he thought it
was a total forgery
um he included in his Canon The Shepherd
of hermus the Epistle of Barnabas uh
which are very very interesting
um
uh books I mean the epistle Barnabas I
mean you talk about antinomianism
whoever wrote the epistle farms and the
Epistle of Barnabas is also in the Codex
cyanidicus which is the oldest complete
New Testament in existence is data is
like 350 of the Common Era the oldest
complete New Testament in existence
that's extant is called the Codex
cyanidicus and its Canon includes the
Epistle of Barnabas and this person
Barnabas who wrote this uh and it's not
the gospel of Barnum Muslims get these
Muslims get these things confused
completely completely different
the epistle Barnabas actually the author
says that the Jews completely
misunderstood all of the dietary
restrictions in the Torah
and that when God said don't eat pig he
means to say don't hang out with people
who are pigs that's what it means you've
always been allowed to eat pigs and then
when he said don't be like the uh hyena
it's because the hyena can switch its
gender so don't be like a man one day
and a woman like another don't be gender
fluid this is what he says the author of
The Epistle of Barnabas and then he says
something really interesting about the
weasel I won't talk about what he says
about the weasel but he can he accepted
that I mean they were Christians whoever
wrote the Codex cyanidicus probably a
committee maybe eusebius of caesarea
because Constantine commissioned uh some
some Bibles this could have been maybe
one of them so it seems like this was
part of the Christian Canon
right uh so yeah I mean if you read the
Gospel of Luke
Luke
um has a preamble and people should read
that preamble people kind of just I mean
they read it quickly and get to the you
know the sort of meat of the issue the
heart of the story as it were but Luke
actually says that it seems like a good
idea for him to write a gospel because
paloy the Greek paloi means many
have undertaken this many there were
many gospels that's what he says at his
time Luke is writing
um according to most historians uh
confessional and non-confessional he's
probably writing around 80 85 something
like that maybe 90. and by that time
there are many gospels written about
Jesus now what are these gospels what is
he talking about
um from a Christian confessional
perspective he could only be talking
about basically Mark and Matthew
and that's about it right uh but that's
that's not many because Luke says in he
says himself in Luke chapter 6 that when
Jesus came to the to Peter and he said
cast your net right he says there were
so many fish in the net that the Nets
were going to break and the word he uses
there is paloy it was poloi fish that
means there were hundreds of fish in
this net so poloi gospels does not mean
two gospels yeah it means possibly
dozens of God where are these gospels
these are lost to history
you know we don't know where they are
every so often some better winners you
know he's in a cave somewhere in Egypt
or in Jordan or something like that I
mean that's how the Dead Sea Scrolls
were found uh what was was discovered
the nag hamadi library right the
nagamati library contains I mean these
are fourth Century documents but
scholars believe that they're copies of
first and second century uh Christian
gospels the Gospel of Thomas many
scholars date that to the first century
or right around the time John wrote his
gospel it's a contemporary with the
Gospel of John wow right and the other
thing is how did how did they actually
pick the Canon how did the Christian the
early church fathers and the
proto-orthodox
uh Church fathers how do they determine
the Canon well basically if something
was
um
proto-orthodox according to them if it
was in agreement with their theology
then they would attribute it to an
apostle
right even if the book is anonymous for
example the gospel of Matthew is
anonymous whoever wrote Matthew did not
identify himself
right but the early church fathers they
they like this gospel they like the
gospel of Matthew
so they said okay fine you know Matthew
wrote it Matthew is a disciple but then
you look at something like the Gospel of
Thomas which is written around the same
time according to many scholars late
first century and the author identifies
himself explicitly as Thomas a disciple
as an apostle because it didn't jive
with the proto-orthodoxy of the church
fathers they said this must be a forgery
right wow so they they decided kind of
what was true about Jesus and then used
as a criteria to
confirm or deny anything that was
written about Jesus that's that's very
interesting so like the god like the
gospel I'll give you no example the
gospel of Peter right the gospel of
Peter according to many scholars late
first century maybe early second century
I mean right around the time acts was
written maybe the Gospel of John was
written the Gospel of John again is
anonymous the gospel of Peter explicitly
claims itself to be authored by Peter uh
but was considered to be I mean like I
said the serapian did
um accepted at one point then he went
back because the crucifixion scene is is
strange it says that when they crucified
Jesus he was silent as if he felt no
pain yeah and they said well what's
going on here what happened was Jesus's
soul may be raptured up into heaven are
they crucifying sort of an empty shell
of a body so they didn't like that right
because Jesus has to suffer for our sins
right his pain is our gain as it were so
uh eventually that that gospel which
explicitly is authored whoever this
gospel said I am Peter that's rejected
but the gospel of Mark which is
anonymous is accepted and Mark is a
student of Peter
according to the Portland Orthodox wow
that's that's that's very very
interesting I mean to be fair to to uh
like Mark and Matthew they were written
fairly early maybe compared to some of
the other ones but this I I think maybe
the comparison is so minimal that like
for example like what you mentioned the
Gospel of Thomas the Jesus seminar they
compiled the book called The Five
gospels and they included the Gospel of
Thomas and they were voting on every
verse that Jesus allegedly said they
were voting on the probability of him
actually saying that so they included
that and as a historical document that
might actually lead to some of the
things Jesus did say historically
speaking so I think that that is very
interesting I do have a super chai here
um I think it's also very interesting
one because uh there's a familiar name
to you and myself Dr Ali recently two
well-known Christian Scholars Dr Dennis
McDonald and Dr Robert J Miller left
Christianity because they found New
Testament problematic mixed
um New Testament I guess scripture
problematically was mixed with
Greco-Roman fiction this is something
that you talked about on Paul Williams
Channel blogging theology yeah yeah I
think it's a blind spot in New Testament
scholarship I think more more and more
people are starting to take it seriously
uh Dr Robin Faith Walsh for example is
now I think she's coming around to this
I think McDonald is definitely on to
something yeah Bart Urban has not come
around to it yet but I think eventually
many many historians will because I
think they're yeah there's obvious
parallels between
uh homeric ethics in particular uh and
the new the the Jesus of the New
Testament uh gospels and so a book that
I recommend is um Homer I think it's on
Homer in the gospels or something the
gospel and the gospel's in Homer I think
yeah Dr Dennis McDonald where he shows
all these different parallels so there's
definitely something there this you know
we talked about this last time as well
this was something that was common
amongst the Hellenistic novelists right
in order to appeal to sort of Their
audience uh they would take a well-known
story and basically replace the hero
within with somebody else in order to
make some sort of philosophical or
theological Point yeah so this was this
was very common could you could you
think of it as like a pop culture
reference in a way or like a meme
yeah maybe it's a yeah you you never you
ever heard of the movie West Side Story
right I've heard of it yeah yeah so they
did a remake of it like a couple years
ago but the classic is a 1961 but that
whole thing is based on Romeo and Juliet
oh wow right so whoever whoever and this
was this was done on purpose obviously
whoever wrote West Side Story in the
1950s was sort of doing an updated
version of Romeo and Juliet so the
gospels are like this as well kind of
updating things with a new hero right
wow so instead of Odysseus now it's it's
Jesus of Nazareth that's not to say that
that's not to say that all of these
stories are false
um but there is a there is a there is a
um an element of various similitude in
other words Mark in particular because
he's the first of the canonical gospels
he's trying to give the impression that
what he's saying is historically
accurate and that's why he includes the
names of many historical figures like
Pontius Pilate but clearly uh many of
the things he's saying in particular the
passion narrative I would argue the
passion narrative strikes me as being
almost completely unhistorical
right and you know I did a podcast on on
that uh almost every single yeah almost
every single event in the passion
narrative has some sort of parallel uh
with with Hellenistic
um a free Christian Hellenistic
literature yeah but you're right about
like the Gospel of Thomas for example
you mentioned that earlier yeah I mean
Thomas has I mean it got the reputation
of being agnostic gospel and this is you
know the word Gnostic in Christian
circles is very derogatory
in in sort of Muslim circles you know an
Arif is actually quite positive like
having madifa of God is actually quite
positive uh but the Gospel of Thomas was
um it was assigned as one of these
Gnostic Gospels which basically means
that that whoever wrote the Gospel of
Thomas believes that it's it's not in
the death and resurrection of Jesus that
gives salvation but rather discovering
sort of the hidden meanings of Jesus's
sayings right uh in in other words
coming into some sort of knowledge that
gives you uh Salvation knowledge or
gnosis right
um so they would say oh that's you know
that's enough but interestingly saying
number 12 in the Gospel of Thomas is one
of my favorite sayings or Jesus says to
the disciples when I'm gone you have to
go to James the just
for whose sake Heaven and Earth came
into being
James the just yeah this is the brother
of Jesus this is the successor of Jesus
in other words all of the Apostles right
all of them are outranked by James all
of them have to follow and Obey James
the just yeah okay uh so that's that's
very important this includes Peter and
Paul and all of them
okay
yeah that's that's it's parallel it's so
interesting because when you
contextualize the whole story in this
way and you really even like for
Christians really question
is what stuck for Christianity true
or was it just what stuck
you really have to ask yourself this
question and
but you know I think I think the brother
to just uh because you mentioned this
earlier the brother is on to something
yeah he's he's completely justified in
in rejecting the Trinity yeah that we we
can chart the Trinity I mean the first
Theologian to use the word Trinity died
in the third century
you know Trinitas is tertullian of
Carthage you know he was the first
Theologian in the Latin West to use the
term Trinity this is a later development
it's very very clear the gospel authors
are not trinitarians yeah okay they're
not trinitarians I mean this is the
standard historical criticism and I
think if if
and of course as I said there are
millions of Unitarian Christians who do
not read the New Testament through a
trinitarian lens the Trinity was not
made Orthodox Christianity until 381.
right uh the the johannan coma first
John 5 7 right so the first Epistle of
John 5 7 it says in the King James
version to this day it's still there in
English it says this there are three
that bear record in heaven the Father
the word and the Holy Ghost and these
three are one
that verse is nowhere to be found in any
Greek manuscript until the 15th century
you will not find a Greek manuscript on
Earth
as of yet that contains that verse and
then the Latin tradition it was somebody
put it into the Latin textual tradition
in the fourth century
right so it doesn't predate the 4th
Century so this verse is an absolute
fabrication to the text
and it's very interesting because I
think I think that young Don actually
mentioned that or he mentioned it about
a certain verse that's in the in the
Gospel of John showing that it was a
complete fabrication so I'm very glad
that he's open to the the idea that some
of the things might be fabricated or
added on the Bible to fit a certain
narrative that is not exactly true now
obviously for for young Don and others
who assert this belief you have to also
open the rest of the Bible up to that
kind of scrutiny because why would you
allow for one passage is not the rest of
the Bible if there is evidence to to
demonstrate that something was added in
or um or that there should be something
that that was missing later on whether
it's the whole gospel a book or some
verses whatever it might be
so I think this whole discussion is very
very interesting yeah and and there and
there are like I said I mean the the
unitarians they they believe in the
Gospel of John they believe in the
prologue I mean there's some there's
some opinion of the story in that the
prologue so John 1
to 18 is maybe a later addition to the
Gospel of John uh but most historians
say no that's that's authentic and
there's a way of reading the prologue
that in through a lens of a Unitarian
that completely works I mean Jehovah's
Witnesses you know they're an
interesting group of people
um you know and they uh the way that
they translate the Gospel of John is
through a Unitarian lens of course
Jehovah's Witnesses they're not
considered to be Christian by you know
the sort of mainstream
Christian Orthodoxy but they really
focus on the meanings of the of the
Greek New Testament right uh so for
example in the beginning was the word
the word was with God the Word was God
and that's the standard sort of English
translation from a trinitarian
perspective in the beginning was the
word and the word uh was with God and
then the Greek says and uh
and a God was the word so the second
occurrence of the word god
in the beginning of the prologue does
not have a definite article yeah and I
think that's important
uh because because Jesus peace be upon
him uh in in no place in the New
Testament and no place in the four
gospels is called hafeos with a definite
article in an absolute and unqualified
sense yeah but only the father is called
the god in the origin of Alexandria one
of these early church fathers in the
third Century he also said you know he
was probably some sort of henotheist in
other words he believes in sort of a
hierarchy of gods but he's not a
trinitarian he said the father is Otto
Theos the very God while the son is
Theos a God or a Divine being
right yeah so yeah he's totally
justified in rejecting
yeah absolutely absolutely I think we
might have lost Dr Alia Thai for a
second but I do want to quote one verse
that young Don mentioned to me to kind
of explain what he believes currently
and it's from First Corinthians it's
writing of Paul where it says yet for us
there is but one God the Father for whom
all things came and for whom we live and
there is but one Lord Jesus Christ
through whom all things came and through
uh whom we live I was just reading from
First Corinthians um something that
young Don mentioned to me to explain his
full beliefs can you repeat it again I
lost you for a second there no it's the
beginning of the verse yeah First
Corinthians 8 verse 6 yet for us there
is but one God the father from uh whom
all things came and for whom we live and
there is but one Lord Jesus Christ
through whom all things came and uh
through whom we live so he's basically
saying that this happens a lot that the
father is called God and Jesus is called
lord and you can please you know let us
know what the word in Greek means for
Lord but when I looked at the dictionary
it could mean like a lord someone higher
than you a master doesn't necessarily
have to mean like Lord God yeah that
verse is very clear
um Paul and is this genuine Paul he
juxtaposes father with God
right the father is God and Jesus is
Lord which means that he's not the God
right Lord is someone else it's
different right
um and another verse uh Paul says I
think also in First Corinthians might be
in second Corinthians he says that uh at
the head of every woman is a man right
so the feminists they don't like this
this verse right
uh and then he says at the head of every
man is Christ and at the head of Christ
is God
right at the head of Christ is God so he
doesn't say at the head of Christ is the
father
right because if he said that then
Detroit will say yeah you know the
father is greater than the son in his
office or in his person in his
hypothesis they have these these terms
that they use to avoid sort of reading a
contradiction and the gospels or in the
letters of Paul
but here he's clearly saying that the
head of Christ is God meaning Christ is
not God
so he's either a different God or he's
no God right well somebody said well
he's called Theos right and he's called
a God in the Gospel of John uh and I'm
sure this brother pointed this out as
well
um and this is known that in Greek chaos
does it necessarily mean a a Divine
entity to be worshiped uh but someone
who has some sort of extraordinary
ability or someone who is sort of
Supernatural not in a sense that they're
Divine but Supernatural meaning that
they sort of are unique in their
abilities as creation for example Paul
refers to Satan as the the God hafeos of
this world the God of this world is
Satan right
um so it's a it's a very nuanced issue
yeah 100 and on that note
I actually wanted to critique a bit of
potential literary
um Nemesis as Dr Dennis McDonald
mentioned so you spoke about the bakai
by
um who was it euripides
yeah
and when you look at Dionysus who is
supposed to be the god or like a god in
the play when you read the kind of
SparkNotes summation of who he is
there's a lot that stands out in light
of what we know Christians believe about
Jesus so I want to read a little bit so
um the principal subject of the bakai
Dionysus possesses a multitude of powers
and can take a variety of forms so you
already have a variety of forms you know
you might say like a a Divine or a human
form and you might say well that's
modalism that's not exactly what we
believe okay no worries in Europe it is
conception of the god however his
numerous forms conform to the logic of
duality
Duality like a dual nature like
hypostatic Union perhaps and uh they're
both one thing and it's opposite
simultaneously
Dionysus is presented as being both
inside and outside the place action
physically he's both beautiful and
fearful by birth he is both Divine and
human the son of Zeus who is the kind of
capital letter G God I presume in Greek
mythology and a mortal woman
the Son of God and a mortal woman maybe
I should share my screen here so you
guys can see exactly what I'm talking
about also while we wait for Dr Alia
Thai too
um his Wi-Fi to to resuscitate
it's okay Angel I think I'll come back
in a second
so let me read this for you guys
so this is where I left off by birth
he's both Divine and human the son of
Zeus who is God in Greek mythology and a
mortal woman
by origin he is both Greek and okay this
stuff doesn't really matter because it's
it's more it's stuff that is specific to
Dionysus Dionysus gifts allow humans to
let go of their troubles through wine
oh okay we got Dr Ali Italy back welcome
back
four one yeah so I mean there are so
many similarities and then when you when
you read
um I believe actually the apostles Luke
or whoever wrote it writes something and
this is something you mentioned on blog
and theology that's very similar to this
the uh hop and sense in this play where
he mentions that Paul
um and him becoming going from solid
becoming Paul is very similar to this
play where he mentions that the God
Appears to him
and basically ask why you persecute me
and then uses a very specific phrase
which is it can kick against the goads
occurs in this play and also occurs in
the acts of the apologies or sorry the
Acts of the Apostles pardon me so yeah
it I don't think it's a fart I mean
you're the scholar but let me know I
don't think it's a far stretch to say
that someone was inspired by this line
of thinking yeah you're a Pity is Baka
yeah pantheus he's on his way to
persecute the dionysian cult his mother
is a part of it and on the way Dionysus
appears to him and he sees a light right
and then eventually pantheus is killed
uh but Paul survives so the author of
Acts who's Luke we can just call him
Luke he seems to be you know sort of
borrowing the story to derive a dramatic
Point home that Paul is similar to
pantheist but Paul is superior because
he actually converted to the religion of
the person who was persecuting but yeah
they both see a a God that they are
persecuting on the road to persecute the
followers of that God and they see a
light and so on and so forth and it's
same phrase why do you kick against the
goads you know it doesn't seem like it's
a coincidence maybe it's a coincidence
you know but it doesn't seem like it's a
coincidence it seems like it seems like
um the author of Luke is borrowing the
story maybe something similar happened
to Paul who knows and and Luke thought
well this is kind of close I'll use this
story because people are familiar with
this story who knows uh Aloha Adam but
yeah that's a it's a very interesting uh
parallel and then of course Dionysus is
the god of wine the johannan Jesus right
uh the the first miracle at the wedding
of Cana
transforming water into wine there are
similar Miracles attributed to Dionysus
the son of Zeus water Miracles wine
Miracles uh you know Jesus says that
Johanna Jesus says I am the True Vine
right I am the true in other words that
other guy is the false Vine that other
guy that you're worshiping dionyses you
know my my rival in the Greco-Roman
world that guy's the false fine I'm the
True Vine right
um so uh yeah I think I think you know
this obviously these there there are
there's a sort of backstory to many of
these things I mean in John chapter 8
it's it's very interesting that you know
the author says that Jesus calls Jews
that that believed in him he says they
believed in him Jesus calls him children
of Satan
right who believed in him why why would
he call Jews who believed in him as
children of Satan it seems to be that
they were Jews at the time that John's
gospel was being composed that did
believe Jesus was the Messiah but of
course that's not good enough you have
to believe that he uh is the Son of God
in some sensor that he died for your
sins
um that's what it seems to be uh
responding to Allahu Adam
uh but uh yeah I mean there's there's
many parallels
um in the book of Acts as well as uh the
gospels the death of Hector for example
uh in in Homer very similar in its
parallels too and then also things that
happen that are just you know I
mentioned this as well in the previous
podcasts uh there are things in the
passion narratives that seem to be just
um highly implausible historically
you know that you know this the the
Jewish San hedrin would meet at night
you know in secret and they would pass a
death sentence on a man after a couple
of minutes and you know not all of these
things are historically implausible
going back to Paul's conversion you know
the high priest he didn't have
jurisdiction over Jews and Damascus
because that's what we're told in Acts
that the high priest he told Paul to
bring those Christians back and uh and I
mean the high priest didn't have
jurisdiction over Jews over essenes in
Palestine who are in his backyard as it
were
um and then when Paul is in the book of
Acts when Paul is defending himself at
his trial you know he says to I think it
was King Agrippa or somebody like that
he says uh King Agrippa says to him
you're going to persuade me to become a
Christian now the word Christian wasn't
around at the time of Paul but it
certainly was around at the time that
the book of Acts was written in the
early second century so this is an
example of a clear anachronism in the
book of Acts uh the word Christian is is
clearly a second century word
um the original Christians were called
nazarenes uh which is uh you know it's a
it's a name that takes uh it's it's it
basically takes its name from from
Nazareth because it was known at the
time that Jesus peace be upon Him came
from Nazareth and they were a Jewish
sect uh that they referred to as the way
hahadas the way this way
oh no I think we lost them again
yeah we lost them again it's okay
inshallah
and the book is delivered to him that is
not learned saying read this I pray thee
and he say or he says I am not learned
Isaiah 29 12 the last prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him yes 100
um this prophesies a man to come and he
would be given a scroll to read and he
will say I am not I'm on lettered all
right welcome back Dr atai thank you
inshallah next time we'll correct the
problem inshallah it's okay it's
completely on my end by the way it's
completely you know me and my technology
yes what was the question 29 12 Isaiah
yeah they were just mentioning it saying
that this is kind of prophesizing the
Prophet Muhammad
yeah although Adam you know um
I mean when we look at Old Testament
passages it really requires a lot of
explanation
um because it depends on how we want to
sort of read these texts and Jews and
Christians believe that these texts have
multiple layers of meaning or levels of
meaning
um so Matthew for example
um in his gospel he says that you know
there's a passage in the Old Testament
that says out of Egypt I've called my
son out of Egypt I've called my son
right uh and clearly in the context of
the Old Testament it's talking about
Israel right the children of Israel
being called out of Egypt but Matthew
applies it to Jesus now somebody could
say well you know Matthew is he's you
know he's butchered the text he's
decontextualizing it but this is not a a
strange way or even an incorrect way of
reading the text in Jewish circles this
is called the remes or Rams right in
Arabic uh it's like it's like an ishara
it's like a sort of
uh subtle sort of exegesis where there
is sort of historical context of the
verse but there's also a foreshadowing
something that's going to happen in the
future and this is a normal way in which
Jews would read their text obviously
sometimes you know you can go with sort
of overboard with these types of things
but the important thing is that
uh a rem as exegesis is valid as long as
you don't violate what's known as the
pashat or the sort of the apparent
meaning of the text these two can never
conflict right so yeah I think there are
passage is probably in Isaiah most
likely in Isaiah and other places that
seem to indicate a prophet at that time
but also May foreshadow another Prophet
to come come in the future
um like 1818 Deuteronomy that that many
Christians believe it's a is a prophecy
of Jesus peace be upon him but if you
look at sort of the canonical context of
that verse
um it seems to be indicating Jeremiah
maybe Joshua uh but Christian said okay
that's that's sort of in the context of
what it was revealed but there's an
indication of a prophet like Moses that
come in the future and clearly for
Matthew that Prophet is Jesus The Book
of Matthew is sort of in five different
sections because he's mimicking the
Torah because Jesus is the new Moses you
know uh but like I said the remnants of
the shot cannot contradict so Isaiah 53
for example this is a classic error that
Christian Exodus will make and say
Isaiah 53 is talking about a literal
human sacrifice
who dies for your sins that cannot be
the meaning
Isaiah 53 is poetry and poetry
uh you know is elliptical
and poetry can never ever
um uh supplant a a clear
unambiguous text something that is
Markham and wander you know so every man
is put to death for his own sin uh
Deuteronomy 20 24 17. that is very clear
there's no ambiguity in that whatsoever
right Lo ish a God is not a man numbers
23 19.
Jose 11 19 I am God and not a man
right and then Isaiah 53 which is very
poetic
right on the surface seems to be saying
something so a Christian if a Christian
were to say oh it's it's saying that God
is going to become a man and die for our
sins that is a that's a violation of the
pashat of the of the
very clear unambiguous
surface meaning of the text uh but this
you know Christian Exodus they have to
find proof text for Pauline christology
and it's very difficult to do that yeah
because yeah because the I think the the
clear verses uh in in the in the Old
Testament uh indicate uh a Unity of God
yeah 100 it's essentially the the
Sharpshooter fallacy it's where like you
shoot a wall and then you draw the
bullseye around your Bullet Hole it's um
you you start with your conclusion then
you find anything that fits it and you
kind of neglect anything that goes
against it this is completely abhorrent
to Jews I did hear that some Jews were
kind of Hellenistic at the Time Around
Jesus or maybe before which which is
maybe why Jesus was sent peace be upon
him that's why there's a lot of emphasis
on worshiping one God because maybe they
were influenced by Hellenistic um you
know Greek beliefs definitely so yeah I
think that's very interesting but I I do
have to get at the Super Chat here
um Morrow said Matthew 4 10 Jesus said
to him away from me Satan for it is
written Worship the Lord your God and
serve him only and then he commented
after saying you've been rebuked so I
don't know exactly what that is
appealing to maybe if you're familiar
with this this point or this argument
um who's who's been rebuked I've been
reviewed I don't know how that rebukes
me I don't know does Jesus here yeah
he's quoting he's quote yeah he's
quoting uh the Torah uh the Quran tells
us that is
that he confirms the Torah so Jesus's
strongest arguments even in the gospels
is when he's quoting the Torah the Shema
is the strongest argument here Israel
the Lord Our God the Lord uh is one
right
um
and so I don't know how that I don't
know what he means by that but yeah yeah
me neither me neither but you know you
actually bring up a very interesting
point and I do want to mention Psalm 91
so I'm going to pull this up on my
screen inshallah for a
brief second and the reason I I'm sure
you're familiar with why I'm bringing it
up but for the for the audience this is
I think a very pro-islamic text in a
very pro-islamic passage found in the
Old Testament that seems to be
prophesying
um is somebody who is to come now I'm
not going to read the full thing I'm
just going to read kind of the end of it
but long story short it speaks about a
person a man who praises god
um and it's more so in the second half
so he Praises God and because of that
God says no harm will overtake you
talking to this one person no disaster
will come near your tent for he will
command his angels concerning you to
guard you in all your ways they will
lift you up in their hands very specific
so that you will not strike your foot
against the stone remember this passage
so you will not strike your foot against
the stone
you will Tread On The Lion and the Cobra
you will trample the great line and the
serpent because he loves me says the
Lord I will rescue him again I will
rescue him I will protect him for he
acknowledges my name he will call on me
and I will answer him I will be with him
in trouble I will deliver him and honor
him with a long life I will satisfy him
and show him my salvation Salvation this
is very interesting Dr aliyatai Y is so
interesting for Muslims
yeah that's um it seems to be a prophecy
of of Jesus I would say it's interesting
because uh
in uh in Matthew Satan quotes this
you know he says it is written about you
you shall not Dash your foot against the
stone or the angels will lift you up
they say oh you see uh Satan is is
applying yeah Satan knows scripture
Satan even Satan knows that this
scripture is talking about uh Jesus uh
and that God will rescue him here's the
thing it's like what's Jesus's name I
mean I mean we look in the New Testament
there's only one man named Jesus but
you know people have been deceived
um because his name in Greek is e Asus
and I Asus if you go to is jeshua right
jeshua in English if you go to a
concordance and you just type in jeshua
there's there's Jesus all over the Old
Testament jeshire is just Josh
right and what does the name jeshua mean
you can go right now to the Lexicon
Strong's Concordance right and just type
in jeshua
people can do that right now
blueletterbible.org and just type in
jeshua and then look at the the meaning
of Joshua he is saved
that's what his name literally means he
is saved it doesn't mean savior
right and it's he is saved uh Psalm so
so Christians will point to certain
things like in the Psalms um in Isaiah
like I said and they said this is a
prophecy of the death of the Messiah
none of those passages that they
uh that they use mention the word
Messiah this Psalm doesn't even mention
the word Messiah but Psalm 20 verse 6
does
Psalm 20 verse 6 and I can read it to
you in Hebrew it says
okay
so David writes in Psalm 20 verse 6 he
says I know that God will save his
Messiah
he shall hear him from his holy heaven
with the saving power of His right hand
is very clear God will save his Messiah
right uh so it doesn't get any more
clear than that
right but somehow Paul got it into his
head that the Messiah had died not only
died but it died for our sins so the
Christians the Paul and Christians had
to find these proof texts and in many
cases that were pointing out things or
looking at things in the Old Testament
and interpreting them in in extremely
figurative and imaginary imaginative
ways that actually violates the pashat
the plain meaning of the Old Testament
or the Tanakh yeah I think that's a
yeah that's very beautifully said and
now this this is for young Don and and
any Christian really who has an open
heart to the whole Bible the Old and the
New Testament I mean look at this verse
from Psalm 20 verse 6 that Dr Ali Tai
just mentioned uh and this word anointed
uh in Hebrew it's it's Messiah that's
that's what it means it's just a messiah
means on the anointed one so now this I
know the Lord gives Victory to his
anointed he answers him from his
Heavenly Sanctuary with the Victorious
Powers right hand so on and so forth so
yeah it's not a very good translation
means to say from bodily harm in Hebrew
so Victory is a bad translation this is
a this is a bad translation I would say
an intentional mistranslation if
anything and young Don has mentioned
that before actually no I think it was
you who mentioned that it was certain
passages were mistranslated on purpose
like uh the verse that says they they
pierce my hands and my feet actually is
like lines on my hands and feet but
that's actually for another another day
I do also want to bring it back to to
Psalm 91 which we quoted before
just to mention again
Jesus was was you know this this passage
was quoted to Jesus we lost Dr Ali atai
again but this passage was quoted to
Jesus Satan
quoted the passage
from Psalm 91 to Jesus where it says
for he will command his angels
concerning you to guard you in all your
ways they will lift you up in your hands
so that your you will not strike your
foot against the stone
right so again let's go back to Matthew
Matthew 4. sorry my laptop's a little
bit slow it's not loading very well no
worries no worries inshallah I'll just
bringing it back to Psalm 91 oh wait I
have to bring you on the stream one
second so are my laptops being a little
bit slow I'm probably gonna have to end
the stream soon because my laptop is
going to give out and if that happens
the stream is done so I was bringing it
back to Psalm 91 and Matthew 4. so the
devil took him to the holy city and how
to stand on the highest point of the
temple and he said if you are the Son of
God he said throw yourself down for it
is written then he quotes Psalm 91
saying Jesus this is about you so I'm
not anyone's about you so if you jump
off God's gonna send his angels to lift
you up so you don't hit your foot
against the stone Jesus answered him it
is also written
do not put your lord do not put the Lord
your God to the test so he affirms it's
about him you know if you come to me and
you say Rami
um are you six feet tall and I say I'm
also handsome then I'm affirming I'm six
foot tall I'm just adding on a little
information for you that's what Jesus is
doing here when you go to Psalm 91 it
specifically mentions that God will save
him from his enemies and Grant him a
long life being crucified by our enemies
at the age of 33 is not exactly that
yeah and show him his salvation and
salvation there because I think it's a
play on words because it's related to
the name of Jesus also in in Psalm 20
verse 6 yes
so it's poetry again but I think there's
a there's a clue the actual name of the
Messiah it's related to yesha it's
Yeshua which means he is saved that's
what his name means
you know but if you read English
translations you read the Bible his name
is Jesus and he's the only one named
Jesus but no his name is Josh
right and Josh is a very popular name
the sixth or fifth fifth or sixth most
popular name of Galilean Jews and it
means he is saved
saved by God
wow
so Jesus's name basically comes from a
word that means he is saved by God yeah
and that's you know you look at the
names of prophets you know like Abraham
the father of Nations avraham because
he's the father of Nations right
God hears right means laughter Isaac
means laughter because Sarah laughed
Moshe means according to Exodus that
means to draw out of the Nile but that's
actually a false that tamology his name
is actually Egyptian it means born of uh
and then question mark is because you
know the woman who had shepsut or Asia
whoever picked him from who plucked him
from the Nile that it knew he was a
Hebrew but didn't know the name of his
God
you know so he's just born of an unknown
God uh so these are indications you know
and so
uh yeah but that's what is that's what
his name means of course the name of the
Prophet sallam the most praised and this
is literally you know he's the most
praised man I mean it's the praising is
happening now somebody right now is
making Avon
this is happening 24 7 until the until
the saw
right yeah um so I mean just the name of
the public system itself is a miracle
it's a prophecy the miracle absolutely
absolutely I think that's beautifully
said now I think it's very important
that we
actually I want to give the floor to you
I think what what you think is best is
is what we should what we should do here
it's up to you if you want to discuss to
Christians or with Christians the
importance of why Islam came
or
if you'd rather discuss
the quranic understanding of Jesus
or if your Wi-Fi wants to cut out
instead
may Allah bless them it's okay inshallah
probably gonna end the stream soon
but um he'll come back inshallah and
then we'll see what he wants to do and
then from there we will continue so I
think it's been an amazing stream so far
alhamdulillah it's um a lot of
information has been shared
it's a lot for people to reflect on and
I think that inshallah people are
sincere they will see the truth in this
and they will question it with an open
heart and really consider Islam
really genuinely consider Islam
all right welcome back working overtime
trying to get your laptop to overheat
he's like sitting over it like with a
with a stove or something
oh yeah uh
who so what what was the last thing you
said yeah so it's I want to know what
you want to discuss next if there is uh
some more time if you want to discuss
why why Islam had to be sent why the
prophet had to be sent why the Quran was
sent or if you want to discuss Jesus
from an Islamic perspective and why it's
not completely crazy or you know or
incompatible with uh what we see
throughout history
yeah I mean we can touch on both of
those and maybe we can expand later but
uh the the prophet Muhammad was sent to
basically restore the true understanding
of God because it had been lost
um you know the Christians
um by the by the 6th Century seventh
century the majority of Christians were
trinitarian uh and this is not the
teaching of Jesus even according to the
young young gone and and many unitarians
this was a Corruption of the injil of
the Gospel
um and then if you look at like the
Jewish law
I mean Judaism is a very interesting
religion if you look at the 613
Commandments that were given in the
Torah the vast Maybe
maybe half of them have really no
application after the destruction of the
second temple the temple was absolutely
Central to uh Jewish identity and so
because of the temple the priest or the
animal sacrifices none of those things
are on the Earth right now so for most
of Jewish history
half of the Torah is irrelevant is
obsolete
um and so this is a good indication I
mean it's circumstantial evidence but I
think it's good evidence that the Torah
was never meant to be the final and
decisive uh sacred law given by God that
something must be coming later
right uh and so the Quran is revealed
and we're given the Sharia which is good
until the end of time uh and theology
had to be restored and true madifa true
knowledge of God had to be restored to
the Earth uh and so this is why the
prophet salallahu said and he was like I
said he's he's the most successful
monotheist by far in human history no
one is even close to him
right yeah
um and so and so Jews in the Middle Ages
Jewish you know medieval authorities
they really don't know what to do with
the prophet like who what do we say
about him because you know we can't be
too harsh because he brought tawheed and
he was more successful than all of our
prophets put together
um so this is one of the major reasons
that he was sent and of course we have
his authentic Sunnah you know we don't
know much about the historical Jesus of
Nazareth
um
you know the author of the last verse in
the Gospel of John says whoever wrote
this gospel he says that there are many
other things that Jesus did and I would
imagine that
to be continued
I'm seeing some some silly comments here
I'm seeing some funny comments here
people are talking about like
um and so on and so forth there's a lot
of deception from God in the Bible by
the way I hope you guys know that
um Jeremiah 4 10 then I said ah
Sovereign Lord how you come how
completely you have deceived you know
these people and Jerusalem by saying you
will have peace when the sword is at our
throat so here you have
Jeremiah and the Book of Jeremiah 4 10.
God has deceived the People by saying
they would have peace and then there was
a sword at their neck
at least in Islam even if we say that
okay Allah deceived Allah is deceiving a
deceitful people so when you deceive a
deceiver you're actually doing something
good
when you deceive a deceiver you're
actually doing something good
but it doesn't even actually mean
necessarily deceiver you know if you
look at the term Market or other
dictionaries they they specify it could
mean deceiver or to deceive it could
also mean a resourcefulness
it could also mean planning and plotting
and that's why and it's so perfect
because the term anything that is
attributed to a human in the same word
attributed to Allah has to have
different meanings because by definition
Allah anything he does is not like what
a human does so if Allah plans it's not
like the planning of a human being
because of Allah's plans is with full
resources without fail and a human being
is just to the best their ability and
their knowledge
so it could mean that the people tried
to deceive and then Allah planned it
could mean that people tried to plot
which is exactly what they're doing by
the way they applauded they sat together
and planned
which is what the verse indicates and
then Allah planned and Allah is the best
of planners
if you look at the context of the verse
there actually isn't really any
deception
that the people were doing
so that that translation would even make
sense there either
bro I swear I blocked this guy I don't
know why he's still commenting unless he
made another account
and I want to block them faster but my
laptop's so slow right now
so forgive me for that guys
okay inshallah so we're gonna go ahead
and end the stream I think it's uh it's
lagged a little bit too much so
inshallah we're gonna end it
unfortunately it's a bit of an Abrupt
ending but I think we discussed a lot
alhamdulillah
and
I'm really trying to mute this guy or
block him before I end this stream
though
I need to find a trusty mod
for these future streams inshaallah
but regardless I want to hear from you
guys in Charlotte love any of you want
to
comment your thoughts insha Allah
yeah there are some real trolls
unfortunately
prophethood ended with Muhammad sallam
so stop the nonsense 100 percent
is the only Prophet who claimed to be
the final prophet he is the only prophet
at least an abrahamic religions who
claim to be the last and final prophet
of Allah
the last and final prophet of God
Jesus didn't even claim this
Jesus did not even claim this in the New
Testament that they have he actually
said a comforter was going to come
man says I'm Muslim and then says crazy
stuff
welcome back
I've never seen this this is so I don't
know what my computer is doing it's okay
no reason like I mentioned working
overtime but okay we're gonna go ahead
and end this stream inshallah we're
definitely going to schedule another one
to uh go deeper into this maybe if
Christians are down they can hop on and
we can discuss with them if you're if
you're up for that as well
yeah definitely
all right yeah
no worries if you if you remember your
your train of thought if you wanted to
finish it before you end off before Oh I
was uh I was saying about um
obviously we believe certain things
about about Jesus peace be upon him that
he was a prophet we believe that he
could perform Miracles but if you look
at sort of our base christology like you
know our sort of Base core beliefs about
who he was it's much more in line with
the historical Jesus than
then the Jesus of Christian faith right
Jesus was I mean if you ask a historian
who was Christ he'll say you know he was
a a prophet he claimed to be a prophet
he claimed to be a Healer
um you know he was a rabbi he was a
scholar of the Jewish law he never
claimed to be God he probably never
claims to be the Messiah there's
different opinion about that
and just that right there is very close
to our christology that we play some you
know that our conception of him is more
coherent than even what Paul was
preaching in the 50s you know this idea
of a dying and Rising savior man God who
died for your sins and
um is he seriously sort of semi-divine
or quasi Divine or whatever yeah
um seems to be sort of
um
more sort of um influenced by other
elements
100 and and for more information on that
you did do a full stream and a full
presentation on blogging theology with
Paul Williams I believe the title of it
was something about the crucifixion of
Jesus do you remember the title
I think it's yeah I think it's uh I
think it's just called Jesus was not
crucified the evidence I think so yeah
yeah I think so I recommend watching
that yeah absolutely 100 and with that
being said
everyone who joined is always a pleasure
having you on and hopefully we do this
again inshallah if you guys have
questions yeah please leave in the
comments and I will make sure to bring
Dr Alia Tai back on with a better setup
inshallah
and uh with that being said any final
words Dr atai
all right amazing
and with that being said
inshallah we'll see you guys on the next
one